hi and welcome to my video series of
mobile explained in three minutes where
I explain the concept in mobile in less
than three minutes so stay tuned and
watch to learn and if you haven't here
subscribe hit that subscribe button
today's video will talk about the
difference between genomic DNA library
and the cDNA library so genomic DNA
library would contain all the
representation of all the genes of a
particular cell but a cDNA library would
contain all the genes that are expressed
at a given point of time at a given
circumstances so in shorter terms cDNA
library each is much smaller than a
genomic DNA library because imagine if a
cell has 26,000 genes genomic DNA
library would have information about all
these twenty six thousand genes but the
serial library won't have 26,000
information about 26,000 genes because
at a point of time 36,000 genes are not
expressed so the cDNA library would have
information about less than - a 6000 of
jeans right now genomic DNA library
contains sequence information about both
intron and exon because now in terms of
genome the DNA comprises of both intron
and eggs on but when it comes to
transcriptome only the exon is trust
only the exon is transcribed and like in
eukaryotes the exon is alternatively
spliced and mrna contains only the eggs
on the CD and I have only sequence
information about the exons about no
introns is there
so in short cDNA libraries has less
information less sequence information
than the genomic DNA library now let's
take a look at what are the vectors in
which genomic DNA library and cDNA
library could be built so the genomic
DNA library could be built on either
bacterial artificial chromosome which
has carrying capacity from 100 kilo base
pair to 300 kilo base pairs or lambda
phage vectors now cDNA library could be
generated using lambda phage insertion
vectors like lambda GT 1011 or lambda
zap series now let's talk about the
genomic DNA library how much we have to
screen in order to get the information
about the recombinants so minimum number
we have to screen is let's say if we
talk about the human genome and which is
2 point 8 into 10 to the power 6 kilo
base pair and we have our insert size
which is 20 KB approximately we have to
screen even more than 1 point 4 into 10
to the power 5 individual recombinants
but in reality the number is way more
which is like 4 point 2 into 10 to the
power 5 recombinants but the number is
way less in terms of cDNA library
because at a point of a given point of
time less genes would be expressed than
that maximum number of genes so let's
see if the 20,000 gene is expressed and
we have total 26,000 genes in human then
number of recombinants to screen in
order to get the sequence information is
well lesser in case of the sequence in
case of the cDNA library right so it's
in simple terms cDNA library is easier
to handle and screen and easily
manageable where else whereas the
genomic DNA library is fast and hard to
manage it difficult to manage so if I
hope you enjoyed this video it's a short
video but it has all the information
that will cover up your ass before the
day of your exam thank you